at this point amiibos are more popular  than some fool on game franchises  Nintendo shipped over 30 million of them  in 2015 they've also revealed which  characters are the most popular the most  popular figure in the u.s. is linked in  his super smash brothers pose for Europe  it's classic Mario and the top figure in  Japan is splatoon inkling girl weirdly  enough the inkling boy girl and squid  were the top three sellers in Japan but  you won't find the inkling girl on any  other top 10 I guess there's no science  behind which characters are going to be  popular Nintendo will continue to create  more amoeba figures and cards in the  future the new animal crossing line is  coming soon but for now you can check  out the full top 10 list of amoeba on  gamespot then stick around for all  nintendo news you need